[Music]
so excited to talk to you guys today I'm
so tired of telling stories about epic
fahad like that like I'm excited to hear
your story so first of all like
congratulations on being too
let's say you're two of three women who
have completed epic five right yeah it's
so awesome
super cool so for people that are just
listening on audio why don't you
introduce yourselves I know you you have
accents that will distinguish yourselves
but I don't want people listening to be
confused yes I am Alexi Yuri mal on the
Australian sorry I do sound different to
future and I am Danielle Grable Danny
the person who's not Italian yeah and
you live in you live in Atlanta
yeah and and Mel you live in Melbourne
yes right yeah cool so this is like a
stop before you're heading to Hawaii
yeah I'm gonna be doing the ultraman
World Championships yes let's say you've
done two ultraman's with Izumi your
first World Championship Hawaii yes
super excited yeah it's not wait so
let's just tell the whole story I mean
first of all how did you guys each get
interested in doing epic five in the
first place well I actually write about
it in finding ultra my parents thank you
yeah write about it in finding alter and
I had this conversation my husband and I
was like listen I read this book and
this guy rich I'm like he is an idiot
you won't believe what you did and I
start telling him all about it
and fast forward a couple years later we
were out in Hawaii my husband did epic
man mm-hmm we met Jason Lester explain
what epic man an epic man was a
traditional triple Ironman so a
seven-point eight mile swim a 336 mile
bike and then a was it a 78 72 mile run
yeah 780 mile run something like that
for 181 miles continuous so that's where
we met Jason Lester and Rebecca and her
whole group and Rebecca's here just off
my grave Rebecca runs epic five now she
if you read finding ultra then you know
that
he was our angel we chasin and I would
have never been able to do it we what we
did without all of Rebecca's tireless
help yeah love exactly so a couple years
after that some somebody that had was
volunteering and posted something about
epic five applications and I just saw on
Facebook and I just sent this kind of
random text message to her and I said
hey I think I was texting either Rebecca
Jen and just said something to the
effect of just curious I just got on the
website like as a woman never done it
before and they said no and then I'm
like really Wow
I was like I think I want to do this and
then so what was that I mean you went
from like this guy's an idiot to you're
like I'm gonna do this well so it was a
woman a woman was owned the race a woman
was putting on the race the primary
volunteers were all women and it just
for some reason kind of bothered me that
a woman had not done it so I felt like
that needs to change
like there's needs to be a woman that
comes and participates in the race right
and it wasn't because they were
excluding women but a women had not
applied right
yeah but up until that point Sam and we
should probably clarify I think there's
a lot of people that think if they just
read finding altra that it was just a
thing that Jason and I went and did and
then it was over with but but Jason and
then Rebecca have kind of taken this
event and made it an official annual
thing so every year a group of people
attempt to do this and you guys amongst
them exactly yeah
what about you though well yes finding
out row with us who was my introduction
as well yeah sorry I first looked at
Ultraman that was my you know that would
be amazing I really want to do that race
and I went you know on the internet
looked out found there was a race in
Canada so I went and did that one and
then afterwards I'm like you know you
know epic five it just still seemed too
big too crazy too out there and I was
talking to a friend and he actually made
a bet with me and he said if you do Fe
500 do ultra and I was like all right
game on
that was all Chuck that was all the to
it well I think in some way in the back
of my mind always knew I was gonna do it
but I just needed to have that yes you
can do more today Vance yes you know you
are actually able to physically do these
things and I do coach men and I got
through that Canada was you know and be
crazy but you know finished that one and
then I went alright well that didn't
kill me so let's go for another couple
of days and let's try something else
so yeah you come from a swimming
background yeah yeah I've been swimming
since I was a kid yeah and what got you
interested in in the world of ultras I
think I think that just you know doing
Iron Man's I did you know a couple I'm
and I was like yeah they're good but
what else is there you know where else
how far can i push this really and I'm
still looking for that limit I still
haven't found that yeah clearly I'm
having no I have not and Danny you
you're you're you're married to an ultra
athlete right so this is like this is a
family affair yeah I'm married to super
talented done everything from 41 mile
swim hundred mile runs triple ironmans
we're doing a thousand mile bike race
together in June so yeah that's crazy so
how do you you train together we don't
we actually don't see much never you
must never see each other like a perfect
relationship actually everybody's like
what's the key and I'm like well we see
each other twice a week so we work
totally opposite schedules from each
other we we do really barely see each
other
it's very that's one of the hardest
things we both did a double Ironman
together and that was probably one of
the hardest things that I've ever
trained for because when I train like
for epic five he literally does
everything he does the grocery shopping
does the cooking he does the cleaning
all I do is work and train so I come
home and everything's it's so blinkered
done done like here's your food and then
what it's his turn and then you do have
for him he's gonna take turns exactly
but the training I mean these are you
know many months of ramping up so that
means that you that have to take a break
or he has to break right and that's how
you balance it yeah and that's really
the only way that it works
especially you know we're self-financed
too so it's not like we have an endless
pit of money to just throw it races
these races are expensive very oh yeah
so you're it's a big commitment I mean
you're you're committing the money and
the time and the energy and then that's
kind of the the give-and-take of our
relationship it's like I'm gonna help
you get through this and then when and
then it's gonna be your turn to do
something kind of like right down the
line right but doing it at the same time
is no bueno
no it's it's the thousand mile bike race
is gonna be a little interesting yeah
why is that because you guys have
different training styles or you just
get on each other's nerves or what I
would love to train with him I was
thinking about my husband and I we do
not train together because we cannot
know like we would just clash the whole
time yeah well we just did a big trip
through Europe and we bike together we
did pretty good so we didn't we did get
if he is in if he's riding with me it
means something's wrong with him
and that's not cool so I don't really
want him to be able to ride with me
because it means even it means that I'm
in amazing shape and he's not right and
that's not a great place to be uh-huh
but I don't want him to but I don't want
him to be feeling bad mm-hmm like I want
him to be faster than me because that's
he should be faster than me right well I
want to work my way up to the why behind
all of this but first I think the best
way to kind of get into that I think is
just is to talk a little bit about the
backstory here because you have a you
Danny have a very interesting path that
got you to this place that I can
certainly relate to definitely yeah I
was overweight and just really kind of
struggling with just kind of every day's
activities walking up the stairs
everything just
Rhian your website it said I think you
were 220 yeah your heaviest and you had
a staircase episode I got dissimilar
from my own I don't know what is going
on in the universe but I read that and I
was like Hello yeah you know I did I did
I had a doctor who really just kind of
laid it all out for me and was like look
like you have a family history of type 2
diabetes high blood
pressure heart disease like it the path
you're going you're 22 years old you're
gonna be diabetic Wow this was happening
yeah uh-huh yeah and had you been an
athlete prior to that hmm no we play
sports uh no no nothing beyond like
cheerleading right but nothing have
always been competitive but not no mmm
necessarily talented most people when
they get that news because a lot of
people get that news they're sort of
told look you gotta eat a little bit
better you got to go to the gym you got
to take care of yourself and I always
sort of think of that as being I mean
it's good advice I suppose but it's so
vague I mean what does that really mean
so when you got that edict from your
doctor how did you translate that into
action well I didn't really even know
how to start because when I say that my
eating habits were poor I mean it was
like McDonald's every day bad like
coffee with sugar and cream I mean it
was just looking back on it now it
almost makes me feel like said it was
your favorite
[Music]
the truth was ordering pizza and dipping
it in ranch dressing ha ha pizza dipped
in ranch dressing it was oh gosh it was
just but it at the time it just yeah you
like that more than cheeseburgers yeah I
could care less about burgers but yeah I
know that was it and so I didn't even I
didn't know where to start buying new
stuff like that wasn't healthy so every
week your nurse now right Oh working
geriatrics I write a home care company
yes so I should that was what was kind
of interesting about it for me was I'm
working with people who've invested a
lot of time and energy taking care of
themselves and that's why they are
living to this age and Here I am like
selling you a service and providing you
this care but I'm never gonna be one of
you right that disconnect yeah it's like
when you roll up to the hospital and you
see like the orderlies or and the nurses
and the doctors outside on the smoke
break that's exactly what it was like
yeah and it's like I'm just I'm never
gonna be one of you like there is
there's their morbidly obese aty a
nine-year-old
don't exist but at 22 you were probably
just still in school right or just
school exactly so at 22 you know there
is no world outside of your little
universe except for when you decide to
start thinking kind of more globally and
you start thinking about the rest of
your life so I started really thinking
about 40 50 60 and what that was going
to look like and it wasn't very pretty
and so what were the steps that you took
to address your diet and lifestyle
habits the first thing I did was quit
smoking cuz I smoked too so I quit
smoking and then every week I would try
to give up one thing and then every
month I would just try to give up
something else and then all my little
changes turned into big changes
haha so it was eliminating things as
opposed to building things in at least
initially was a little bit of both and
then reinforcing rather than rather than
approaching it from like deprivation so
thinking like you you're you can't have
this I would always try to associate how
good I felt when I ate fruits and
vegetables versus french fries uh-huh so
instead of saying well I can't have
fries it was never that like oh you
can't have that it was just that I'm
choosing to have a banana because that
makes me feel better right it's still a
huge gap between quitting smoking and
stopping dipping pizza and ranch
dressing - doing epic five though I mean
so walk me through the process it's you
sir I just I joined the gym and I but
first I mean I couldn't even get through
I have a cousin who had a polo girl like
a Pilates and yoga video and I couldn't
even make it through that home exercise
video so my goal was when I can make it
through one hour of her video then I'm
gonna go to the gym and then I would go
to the gym and I would just try to do
like 15 minutes on each piece of cardio
equipment impossible because I couldn't
do more than 15 minutes mmm and then
eventually that led to the spin class
and then a spin class led to meeting
people who do tripods and I was like wow
and so it was just literally like every
little step like oh I think I can do a
sprint triathlon and then like Mel was
saying every time I would finish
something you'd be like wow that was
great but I think I can do more
and then so just a very gradual process
of like increasing yet pressure and the
Ironman and you're like mmm that hurts
but me and there's like more out there
yeah like there are people are doing
things that are just crazy and crazier
like I want in on that what do you think
that the thing is I mean people who you
know tackle a difficult difficult
challenge of course there's a great
sense of accomplishment but I feel like
people have one of two reactions in the
wake of that they're like that was
awesome that was great
never again or like sign me up for the
next one immediately how can I go harder
longer faster what do you think that
difference is about like I mean
obviously you both chose the latter some
people don't like the process though
some people yeah this my experiences
everybody wants the finish line
everybody wants the medal but people
don't want to put the work in nobody
like when people I'm very open about
epic five and Iron Man's in the training
and people like that's great I think I
would like to do that I'm like what I'll
show you all my training
no never mind yeah so people want to say
they did it but they don't want to
really get up at 4:15 in the morning and
what they miss is that the real gift I
mean looking back on it now yeah you can
remember finishing these races but the
real value when you reflect back is that
process like I'm sure when you think
about it it's like I remember that day
like when it was pouring rain yeah I
want to go out to train and I did I went
out anyway like that's that's the gift
yeah exactly
and I also think that people choose in
their term time of life that yes I'm
gonna commit to this at this time and
then it's not gonna happen again
like that's just you know life happens
and different things happen and they go
alright this is gonna be my six months
where I put it all in and then I'll move
on to whatever whatever after that as
well so yeah and I suppose it's worth
saying like look not everybody has you
know 30 hours a week it is like a job if
you want to show up yeah only prepared
absolutely and you have to reconfigure
your life to prioritize that I described
as having two full-time jobs yeah when
I'm training
mm-hmm yeah there's no question about it
yeah alright so what was it like for you
mouth
like getting getting I mean it sounds
like you've been doing this for a long
time it was more just part of who you
always have been Oh sort of I did sport
when I was a kid you know like Ryan's
call it's for what do you call it I went
to University Hospital with swimming
what we saw in bathers oh yeah yeah
there's yeah what do they call the
speedos for the guys in Australia oh
buddies yeah yeah I went I was in
Australia I went to manly beach and they
were like this is the home of the the
budgie I guess there's a company called
budgie smugglers that spell space yeah
yeah we have Fame yeah I mean yeah
wasn't wasn't that because I grew up in
the country I grew up in the middle of
nowhere you know I tell people where I'm
from Hill from Australia and they the
first question is where's that but not
on the spit no no what's that movie
never mind
I can't I'm nervous okay so yeah like I
parents had to drive us anywhere that we
went so you know my brother and I would
play sport you know we'd play basketball
and things but it's all just local you
know just play with your friends
micrograms like nothing serious yeah I
was never competitive you know any other
any things I was doing and then I went
to uni studies and I wasn't really doing
anything at that time and then my
brother got married in 2005 and I was
looking back over the wedding pictures
and his best man
I'm gone off and joined the Navy and
he'd gotten really feet and he looked at
me was like let's go for a run and I was
like ah okay sure cuz you know I'm like
what wasn't really doing anything I'd
put on a bit of weight and so the
morning of the wedding was actually the
first time I'd really run for years and
and I was sorry I saw that night I was
thinking about that the other day and
then yeah like you know I ended up
having a news resolution and I'm like
alright time to get fit time to focus on
your health you know you're starting
working now you know let's be a bit more
serious about this and so yeah you know
I
and I was working on the ninth floor of
the hospital so I just walk up the
stairs to every shift you know you get
there and you know take five minutes to
catch your breath and everything but I'm
like whatever you know and started
eating a lot healthier and then I saw a
friend do a triathlon and I'm like that
looks really fun I need to actually
start running more because I'd never
really run had never been you know I've
been riding my bike and I've been
swimming but not not you know anything
seriously
so you know I started you know I signed
up for a 5k and then a 10k and then did
a couple of triathlons and just
absolutely loved it like they were the
little mini baby ones I'm like you know
250 meter swim 10k run a 10k ride and 2k
run and I'd always noticed my run would
be the worst out of all my three legs
that I was doing so I was like okay you
need to focus on that need to you know
build that up a bit so I signed up for a
half marathon the next year so I was
like well that'll give me a big run
focus so I did that and it was that was
my first taste of doing something a bit
longer and I across the line I was like
that was amazing I want I want more of
that like that was that was really cool
so then yeah just kept progressing and
getting longer and longer so then I did
you know Olympic Distance race and then
2008 is when I started doing like half
Iron Man's then Ironman and then you
know just kind of kept going okay so
what's next what's next and no one I do
my first half ironman or 70.3 my first
words when I cross the finish line was
that was amazing I want to do another
one
so I signed up for another one do at six
weeks later doing that so why I mean a
lot of people that get into this they
work their way up to Ironman and then
they just try to progress within Ironman
to get faster better an Ironman to get
to Kona so what was it that that spoke
to you or that appealed to you about
making the leap into the ultra world
like what's different about the
traditional triathlon
you know marathoning world versus the
ultra world for you guys well I think we
were talking about this earlier today
and we've literally four people that
just met each other we've talked about
almost everything humanly possible since
we've talked on the phone a couple times
do you guys train together No
we just met you guys today say oh you
did yeah cuz you didn't pick five on
different years yeah but we had talked
to each other beforehand yeah I talked
to her yeah but we just like met each
other Friday night it was amazing
or no Monday Monday Monday we both were
just just talking about that earlier
like I'm a diesel like I am the kind of
person just give me some you know give
me some food and just send me on my way
and I'll come back in ten hours like but
my pace doesn't stop so for iron man you
know have a lot of respect for people
that that do you want to get fast and
want to make it to Kona and I think
that's incredible but for me that's just
not what I'm gonna be I'm not I'm
there's only a certain amount of weight
that I'm gonna be able to lose like I'm
just not gonna be able to do that I am
made to go forever like that's just what
I'm designed to do so I realized that
like the longer distance races my bike
times and like my swim times from 1/2 to
full like it wasn't changing this is
really weird
yeah and then I was like I just want to
keep seeing if I can keep holding this
pace and then like you do a double army
and I'm like ah my swim was just about
the same for a regular Ironman so I
guess you realize at some point that
like you're not gonna get that much
faster so you have to start going longer
right like when you're kind of made for
the own like you we were I think we both
probably realized at some point like
were made to go longer yeah yeah my
first coach that I had had always said
I'm a diesel it's like you know exactly
the same you can just go all day as long
as you have enough food and water you're
just you know 1012 hours
fine I'll just keep going I don't you
know that yeah that's that's where I
find my enjoyment yeah I'm the same way
you know now I go around and I do like I
go to events and they'll be like a fun
run or a group run and it's like listen
guys like I ain't that fast
yeah we're gonna run around the block
like you guys are gonna crush me you
know like this is
race and that kind of thing that Lane
takes me a very long time to get up at
speed and I get to whatever that speed
is and I can just hold that yeah yeah
that's a very specific skill that works
very well in ultras but isn't really
translatable to anything else finishing
the ride I'm like oh I just I feel
alright so epic five so Danny you did it
first right in 2016 and that's how you
did it last last yeah 2017 my memories
you know of doing it in 2010 or as fresh
as ever
you know life-changing for me and I
would imagine for both that you guys as
well absolutely
hmm yeah yeah so let's talk about it is
the race course the same Rebecca is at
the st. did it change I would change it
it's kind of there's always some kind of
curveball condition right that throws it
off and you have to adapt or whatever I
think for from what I understand for
both of you guys like day three was the
hardest day in Molokai yeah definitely
yeah that was my hot day
that was the day yeah our day three we
were trying to land and next thing you
know the planes going back up in the air
and I'm like wait a minute
I think they're landing this plane and
next thing you know we're back in Oahu
and we're sitting there and we're in the
airport and we'd been there for maybe
like an hour hour and a half and Rebecca
comes up and she's like and we had all
there was only three people in the race
at that point we were wearing our
bathing suits our bathers we were
wearing them because we were ready but
we were trying on the plane yeah on the
plane because we were trying to be so
efficient with time so Rebecca comes up
and she's like hey listen we're gonna
have like we need to change plans like
we're gonna have to to run like nine
miles to the pool
this isn't like when we get in I'm like
my first resort there were sharks that
year right he couldn't swim right so
we're swimming in a pool but she was
saying like we don't have enough time
like when we land you you have to start
racing and I just looked at her and I
was like but I'm wearing my bathing suit
she's like well it's okay like you have
time to put your run clothes on so we
the plan lanes everything the plan yeah
the plan got on the ground suitcases
come out clothes running clothes
it's literally like put your running
clothes on as soon as you can and just
start running right awesome yeah that's
why it's called a challenge yeah and it
was um so that was the first kind of
change of the day so we ended up
starting probably three or four hours
later than we anticipated mm-hmm and
then from there the day the day got
tough the day got really tough it was it
was a hard day so when I finished my
husband said okay you have 30 minutes
before we have to be at the airport do
you want to eat sleep or shower and I
was like well of course I want to sleep
so I just jumped in the van and tried to
sleep for 30 minutes and I dozed off and
I woke up you're there for it right so
let me understand so when we did it when
Jason and I did it we did obviously
Kauai was the first day right we're in
we ran the marathon first we start at
like 3:30 in the morning or something
like that
mm-hmm and you know finished at the
airport you know with three seconds to
spare before getting on the plane to get
to the next island flew to a Wahoo we
had all kind of remember that was
Rebecca I remember that's where we like
lost the bolts and our bikes and it was
like a whole disaster the next day so we
didn't even get going the next day until
like 10:30 a.m. or so I was like that
was our Mullen high crazy yeah and we
finished so late that it was like 2:00
in the morning right when we finished I
think yeah it was super late and so
that's where we have to take a rest day
so for us then we went to Molokai and
actually we felt pretty rested Molokai
because we had a little bit of a buffer
there okay we didn't do it in five days
like you guys did so I can imagine had
we made that deadline that Molokai would
have been really tough yeah now he was
definitely the hardest it was the
hottest it was the windiest but you guys
got a second wind when you got to Maui
yeah yeah absolutely yeah so for me
Molokai was hard because my hamstrings
locked up on the marathon and I had to
walk about 30k to finish that day
because I hadn't been doing any of the
body maintenance that you normally do
your stretching it rolling like anything
like that it might like so just like yet
nari oh there's no time to pay tonight
exactly you're not eating sorry what's
the point there's yeah there's no time
for anything like that yeah and like
again it was it was really really hot
that day and yeah I was just mentioning
just really really struggling and I
remember on the run on day three I was
you know getting quite emotional about
everything and I was saying to my
husband I'm like oh my god I'm gonna
keep you guys up he's like it's fine
don't worry about I'm like oh okay and
then I just relaxed and went alright
well I'll just walk it in like I don't
care it's fine and then um yeah so Maui
we ended up starting a bit later cause
our swim buoy oh wait come on boy swim
boy disappeared I think so and so then
like there was a bit of logistics of you
guys sorting out what to do with you
know the swim and in the swim ended up
being longer or something I don't I
don't exactly know what happened was it
the same beach Rebecca or Kihei Beach
yeah all I remember is getting out and
seeing six guys on my Garmin that's one
for two hours and I was like oh oh well
that's done now what are you doing yeah
yeah I think some people get stressed
about it but I was like well you know I
can't do anything about it can't change
it and move on to the next thing
yeah I had I had a bunch of flat tires
in Maui as well and we're riding along
the dock and I was trying to figure out
cuz I knew my crew was behind me on one
of my when I had a flat because I just
swapped out wheels which was really
really handy but I was like how are they
gonna see me it's in the dark so I lay
my bike down and faced it towards the
roads they might see my bike light and
they didn't like that cuz like I thought
you'd pull it off and like freaking out
like it's okay sorry yeah but um I
remember someone said you know you're
lucky if you get sleep in Maui like
that's you know it basically doesn't
happen I didn't see the inside the hotel
room like you know he didn't either on
day three no day three yeah and that was
Mike from Maui that was my big thing was
I have to sleep yeah like I was like I
don't think you understand like today's
the day that so when I got off the bike
I remember looking at Mike and I said am
I gonna sleep he goes not if you had to
run like you did yesterday and I was
like oh no done
I was like that was it I was like oh
yeah I am my head is on a pillow tonight
right yeah so for people that are
listening you know it's it's daunting
the prospect of attempting to do five
iron man's in a row and then you add in
getting from island to island it makes
it all the more difficult but I think
what perhaps is underappreciated
is the logistics and the travel that's
really as challenging it's like once
you're on your bike you're like okay I'm
good it's like all that other stuff
that's super taxing and it's really a
challenge in sleep deprivation as they
yeah anything yeah
when we did it we flew like we had a
bunch of night flights but the only
night flight you guys had was off of
Kauai right at all the other lights were
in the morning yes she'd get up in the
morning you'd have to fly to the next
Island and then do right into doing an
Ironman
yeah after you've been on an airplane
and you've been traveling and you're
schlepping gear around yeah yeah they're
starting the race was literally
dependent on and it was the crazy thing
in the world to like not be able to
drink so it was like okay wait a minute
you're about to go do an Ironman but you
can't bring any water through security
and like we got to Molokai and there was
no water like there was no water there's
nothing I need to eat I need something
like I need like where am I gonna and it
was just it was it was against kind of
the whole idea of the minute you
finished your long training you should
refuel you should rest yeah and legs up
yeah take an ice bath like all that
stuff was done like all the stuff I did
in training like all the recovery drinks
everything gone right go eating whatever
you could never you could yeah I
remember when Jason and I finished the
first one in Kauai and we were like
literally the plane was taking off we're
trying to get through security and we're
still on our bike kits and everything
I'm like shopping our gear we're like
yelling and wait you know like trying to
get it through and we had all this
performance nutrition liquid performance
nutrition like never our ass and all
this kind of stuff that guys like you
just pouring it out like hundreds of
dollars or like stuff the whole week you
know and I'm like so you guys had your
your husband's recurring for you right
had your own distinct crew yeah Rebecca
was basically crewing for
Jason and I essentially by herself we
had people that would show up on each
Island like who volunteered out of the
kindness of their heart yeah really
Rebecca's trying to manage all of this
like a hundred you know and it was just
it was an unwinnable you know yeah yeah
world is on fire I want Rebecca like
helping that like the logistics so for
her just to be able to think on our feet
in Molokai and come to us and not be
dramatic about it and not be making a
big deal but just be like hey guys guys
well like you need to you need to just
run like you're need to run to the swim
people don't realize like what a value
that is in a race director that not
everybody can do that
and that's part of putting these events
on that if you didn't have somebody like
her like it wouldn't be happening like
they just wouldn't it wouldn't be taking
place yeah yeah a great look yeah
because we had one guy in Molokai whose
bike didn't make the flight so like okay
we'll just do part of the marathon you
know when it comes and you know like
after the swim yeah and then there was a
local who just rode with him as well
like it's just things like that I'm like
where who else would do that what el the
race would do that just to make sure
everything possible it wasn't that yeah
you can be successful you have to be
malleable and adaptable absolutely you
can't be like well here's my race plan
and go it's like you know within an hour
of beginning it like that just goes out
the window and some variable gets thrown
at you exactly yeah you're gonna have to
contend with it I think that's as much
about what that event is about as just
covering the distances yeah you're not
gonna be successful if you are black and
white and you can't operate in anything
outside of well this was what my plan
was then you're not gonna yeah it will
crush you actually part we're just being
able to adapt and being able to just do
whatever and being able to eat this food
that you've never had before because
somebody gave it to you and you just
have to realize you just have to go with
it yeah oh I got a flat and I don't know
where my crew is and there's no cell
service and like what am I going to do
yeah there's no eight stations no no
I mean just but still remaining like the
attitude part is important and that's
yeah the difference between people who
are successful in people will be like
well what does it take and it's not just
the training but I'm like you just
you've got to be grateful I mean you
have to focus on the fact that this is
an opportunity and it's a privilege I
mean the Mac that you're here and you're
able to do this and you're motivated
enough and people care enough about you
like you're it's it's a privilege don't
be out there whining and complaining
with a bad attitude because you're not
gonna make it yeah yeah and that really
gets tested because when you compound
the level of fatigue with the sleep
deprivation was not complain did you
were you successful yeah Rebecca is she
telling the truth I complained a lot I
was I was a baby yeah I had a diet a
couple like Rebecca could tell you I
mean I talked about him in the book I
was trying to be as honest about that as
possible like I had several moments
where I thought I was gonna break and I
just was a I was a baby I was an
immature baby yeah cuz I was so
exhausted I know it was really the sleep
deprivation yeah oh yeah I saw I saw
cats
I saw animals I thought a woman was
racing me on the last day because she
was just walking and I was like what is
she doing out here why does she racing
me somebody needs to tell her that this
is my fifth day out here yeah she was
all right oh no I saw a lot of people
that cows were talking to me I'm not
going along yeah yeah they're
encouraging me it was amazing yeah yeah
I think probably for me like 90 percent
of time I was on top of the world I was
like I can't believe I'm doing this like
this is you know I think it was like two
three years I decided to do it before I
actually was there and like this is
amazing like I had a couple little
moments you know I called my princess
moments where you kind of have a little
mental breakdown just for you know those
for a few minutes and then you're like
all right yep sorted let's continue on
it's fine yeah and I always associate
that with food like I think I need to
eat more so just anything else I'm like
I can't feel good now
keep going and no matter how much you
eat you're gonna be running a caloric
deficit yeah you're waking up hungry
every morning yes and are absolutely
eating constantly yeah even when in
moments when you're not hungry you're
always eating for six hours like what
you know what's gonna be happening six
hours from now tomorrow staying on top
of that yeah
my mentor was um I had to eat for day
five I had to eat enough to get myself
to day five to be able to then finish it
yeah that was always in my mind all the
time and my crew actually wrote down
what I ate and I was showing to people
they're like oh my god so you could like
look at it at the end yeah afterwards
yeah what happened to me I don't know if
this happened to you guys was that I
thought like oh man by the end of this
thing I'm gonna be I will have lost like
15 pounds there's just no way around it
yeah but actually I got progressively
more and more bloated yes and I felt
like super you know it's the combination
of inflammation and also your body
trying to hold on to everything because
it thinks you're trying to kill it yeah
and then like 10 days after epic five
was over like all the weight went away
and I got like super emaciated all of a
sudden it was like oh we're safe now
chasing me here my coach told me that
was gonna happen and I was like there's
no way like I don't and that's exactly
what happens yeah yeah issues access to
food yeah finished it was like all right
now - wait what did we eat and they're
like there was nothing
we're just wasn't I was surprised how I
greatly underestimated the access to
food and just thought that we would go
to these airports and we'd be able to
grab food yeah we're doing so with the
Thai food I I was like I kind of went
after you in the book about that you
know I was like Thai food again is
terrible greasy
like yeah she's running around like
doing the best that she can and I'm like
in Mullica I think it was I was so
hungry and I it was this volunteer Scot
he handed me um what was it Mesabi the
spam sushi like sushi that was made with
spam in it it sounds hard no idea what
it was but when I ate it it tasted so
good because it was so salty I kept
eating it I was like oh this is amazing
this is so good in Kona my crew found
some sabi and they gave it to me I was
like what is this garbage
you just ate it yesterday and you loved
it I'm like oh wow just right yeah my
taste you've totally changed and I don't
like it anymore
Molokai is a really special place it was
that guy who lived there who really
thought will yeah yeah will did he ride
with you guys he's like the tour guide
you can believe RX along you can believe
this wills parents live in the same town
that that I'm from really like we know
the same people oh wow this is the cool
this is the cool story about well so he
told me that he had been out every
single year since the race started right
and the year that I was there he brought
his daughter and she was what maybe
eight or nine years old she met us at
the airport the first thing she does has
RuPt me start asking me a million
questions and he was like I'm really
sorry and I was like why are you
apologizing he's like my daughter is so
excited that you're here she's never
seen a woman do the race so when I was
doing the run and I was putting my fuel
bet on what's that what are this bottles
for what are you gonna do this a machine
was just fascinated with everything and
I got so overwhelmed and when all of our
bikes were lined up and he was like oh
that's probably not her bike because of
the gearing I had I had I didn't have as
many gears as the other guys and then he
was like when you came up and that was
your bike I was trying to explain to my
daughter like that's a girl riding a
bike with really big gears and it was so
overwhelming and then to find that
connection it was the coolest thing and
I told Rebecca initially that I didn't
want him to ride with me I was like no I
don't want to ride with them
like no this is your island that he
somebody's gonna ride with you and it's
gonna be Willa I'm like now it's okay I
don't what if I don't like him what he
talks to me what if he messes me up I
don't really want to ride with anybody
and then it ended up being perfect like
we had that connection we knew all the
same people in Atlanta it was so cool
that's wild yeah that's why well Molokai
is is such a unique place and it was my
favorite Island because it's the purest
you know it is as close to its natural
state of any of the Hawaiian I mean one
stoplight very many people live there
more churches per capita than anywhere
like on planet earth because of the
leper colony you know for that's what
it's most known for and just super like
weird and diverse and strange you know
from the kind of a banded developments
they worked so hard to prevent hotels
and resorts from yeah being there and
there was like a big fight over that one
side of island where now there's kind of
like half built buildings but you know
it's still it's it's so quiet and I
don't know there's something I think
really cool about that place yeah it was
kind of neat and of course I wanted to
ask a lot of questions and learn so but
we saw people wearing shirts like keep
Hawaiian Hawaiian and I wanted to know
all about that so we learned about it
but then the people were so nice to us
like they weren't it was like they
understood you're just visitors and
you're here doing this thing and then
you're gonna leave and you're not gonna
leave trash anywhere and you're gonna be
nice to us so we're not gonna be mean to
you yeah it was really cool it was so
funny going past some locals and I just
not looking at going what are you what
are you doing like what's actually going
on here my everybody would know because
like yeah like the fact that anything
was happening they're like oh my god
something's happy when I mean it was
like half the town showed up like all
these kids came out and ran with us and
all the teachers from high school and
who are those kids the account the a
Kona kids like there was like one like
one teenager and his younger brother who
came out and ran like through the night
with us while their parents drove next I
mean it was really something special
it's cold yeah because they were like
wow there's something cool happening
like everybody turned up to support us
that's
which was really awesome and now then it
goes back every year I would have
thought like it just yeah we had the
local volunteers cuz I had a guy that
just happened to be there it was in
medical school that was from there and
it was just these random people with
these random stories like oh yeah I know
this race happens every year and I just
happened to be here so I'm gonna run the
whole thing with you and I'm in medical
school and I live in New Jersey and I
but I grew up here and I'm like these
people come from how you did the whole
Ironman he did he did the whole run he
stayed out on the run with me he's a
runner so he was a kid I mean he was
just just doing his first year of
medical school she's so awesome ya know
what about you um yeah like I had three
people in my crew and sorry
like they'd all just taken interns
running along and because it was ten of
us in the year that I did it last year
so that it wasn't as kind of small and
yeah and interesting when you did it
there were more but when one person
drops out after the first day right see
there was only three of us so if
volunteers were showing up they were
really yeah yeah it was a really kind of
one-on-one experience for sure with the
volunteers yeah with ten people yeah we
didn't you were taking over the whole
island yeah we really were yeah so we
didn't really have so much of all the
locals like coming in and doing a lot of
stuff it was more yeah we were just kind
of managing it ourselves but it was cool
because like my crew you know when they
come and run with me then they tell me
stories about what their day had been
like because I'm like well you know
let's let's chat you know I haven't seen
you like you've been passing me stuff
all day but haven't had time to talk to
you
and they were saying they're constantly
getting questions for every island
people coming up going so what sees
what's going on what's happening and
yeah they found that really really fun
yeah that's cool yeah
Oh wahoo is interesting because you have
to deal with the you know the congestion
you know it's such contrast to Molokai
yes I just remember you know trying to
just get out of Waikiki and Honolulu to
forever yeah and then you know you're on
the other side of the island it's
beautiful its pristine but then kind of
making your way back into Honolulu it
was like stoplight stoplight stoplight
and I just remember it just drained me I
was like is this bike ride ever gonna
end like I just want to ride and finish
it but because of traffic and just in
the urban metropolis it took so much
longer so Rebecca would do it was of
course this the bike course the same
oh you changed it okay that's cool yeah
yeah cuz that was a problem but the
merit is the marathon course still out
on that Highway you burn up Diamond Head
right I had checked the jet with me
oh we a chat he never stops he did the
whole thing with me I was like this is
that was my treat that was my big ol
tree it was heaven ships lane hooch at
the jet is is like I met got is a world
class character it really is and I have
to tell you is somebody he like grew up
in Georgia and we go to Hawaii and we're
new to ultrazoom Jason's doing this
triple Ironman and we land in Hawaii I'm
training for a 400 mile bike ride across
Florida I'm trying to break this record
and just hear shows shows up this guy
chat with his bike like hey take this by
clicking ride this biker and I'm like
what like who are you telling me he's I
mean to legend double deca finisher
played a hundred hours of tennis
non-stop for charity once I mean if
there's something that Chet is gonna if
there's a way to spin it but in the most
humble way I mean not because he wants
you to know that he's chatting he's done
these incredible things because he truly
is like that hungry just to figure out
what what all he can do yeah it's kind
of like he's kind of like Jack LaLanne
in a bit like that and I don't know if
you noticed but when he sends emails or
posts on Facebook he does it in all caps
and lots of exclamation points no matter
what he's saying
I always think you're yelling at me
because you know you got to stop with
the cap locks man that's his thing but
he's so funny and he's just so awesome
and his wife speaks no very little
English and they have this awesome
relationship and I'm like how do you
guys even talk he's like you know
Universal body language he's just so
cool and so going there and having him
like having met him and then I went and
crewed him down in Florida at a double
Ironman in being able to kind of keep
that connection I'm in and having him it
was like we never skipped a beat like
when I saw him I hadn't seen him in 2 or
3 years but it was like that was it like
we just he talked the whole time we told
stories like we were best friends and
talked on the phone every day uh-huh
yeah that's awesome it's cool yeah
came up and said hi and said that he's
making you the UFO yeah yeah and he run
with you as well Noorie now I had my
crew who are running with me yeah yeah
we just came out to say hi and yeah yeah
who's fun yeah I just remember a whole
bunch of people from the her team like
the Hawaiian you know ultra runner Lulu
that live on Oahu like turned up and it
was like a weeknight you know we didn't
start until it was definitely dark when
we started running that day I can't
remember exactly what it wasn't that
late but I was like alright they'll run
five or six miles and then you know they
all have jobs or whatever in this like
like no there's like a couple of them
peeled off but most of them ran the
entire marathon with us at night just on
awake just because or whatever and like
Chet was like right there
that's what Chet did and we finished
late like two o'clock in the morning or
something
no wonder it seemed and I was like do
you go to work tomorrow and he's like
yeah I know I'm like see people not good
he's like oh no it's cool I'm going to
work like that's right district whatever
on a random marathon and in the middle
of the night on a weekday and go to work
but that's all of it totally that's
that's the kind of people that you meet
like that's yeah these these are the
people that are out there yeah yeah yeah
it's uh and it's it's sort of surreal to
be like running through Waikiki with all
those shops and everything like that
after being in you know the more remote
areas of other islands yeah yeah that
was really funny running down you know
Waikiki Beach with all these people you
know these tourists and all these people
cuz in the afternoon the Sun was shining
the beach was pumping and we like
running along doing a marathon awesome
about it is that like no one even knows
what you're doing
yeah idea tourist on Diamond Head they
had all these like people stopping and
taking pictures we'll excuse me excuse
me yeah really
people just no Cleo no Glassman and
really the strategy with all of this is
you you don't want to go too hard right
because there's no reason to overly
deplete yourself like the flights still
gonna leave when the flights gonna leave
so you're sort of I call it like
persistent conservation like you want to
keep moving you don't want to go too
fast and overly exert yourself
unnecessarily yet the longer you're out
there the longer you're out in the heat
and the ones asleep you're gonna give so
you're like trying to balance these
things to try to maximize the amount of
rest you're gonna be able to get without
kind of tipping too far into
overexertion mode right so how did you
like gauge that for yourselves I found
on day when it was really hard and I
didn't know I just kept going especially
on the run because that's what's gonna
beat you up you know I was like yeah
well one of run and walk and I do the
run walk from the hole that very you
know first marathon but I was like you
know I feel ok I probably could run a
little bit faster but I don't want to
and I was like ah and I was always
questioning I'm like I know I'm gonna
get through this I'm not gonna do it
that was never a doubt in my mind but it
was how I was going to do it and it
wasn't until I woke up on day 2 and my
body just felt like I'd been out doing a
normal training day as I was doing you
know I've been out you know riding and
running for 8 hours or whatever
and I just had that level of fatigue and
I was like oh ok yeah I've got this
that's fine and that's when I had that
ok now I know how to do this and how to
get through this yeah but it wasn't it
wasn't until that point and that was a
concern and no one that I was able to
talk to you would have an answer because
they didn't know what I could do so I
was like I don't know yeah I mean I
could ask daddy but she doesn't you know
we have very different people in terms
of like pacing and things so it's like
you just have to figure it out so you
don't know ya know you're doing yeah
yeah I was fortunate in hindsight kind
of fortunate so mile 46 I cracked a rim
on my bike so I ended up spending like
an hour and a half off the bike on the
first day so it was a lesson in patience
because I ended up getting passed so I'm
a lot stronger cyclist than anything
else so it's unusual for me even in a
field where I'm with men it would be
unusual for me to be not kind of up
there with them so that was the whole
deal with me in in the first two islands
cuz in a Wahoo I spent maybe two hours
off the bike and to leave your little
bike computer on and see it go down to
like 11 miles and
and I was only at the halfway point and
I remember Rebekah saying like you can't
get back on the bike and hammerite like
I know that you can but you can't mm-hmm
and she was completely right like I had
to just be it was a huge ego check like
a huge I am capable of going faster but
I can't right and I should you have to
have the long term goal in mind yeah in
the fact that I've been off the bike for
an hour and a half or two hours I was
like just Jesus an opportunity to eat
food and to get you know to rest and to
hydrate and I'm and just be patient
like it was patience like it's okay just
add it here on Kauai I mean there's one
bike shop right yeah so if you break
down I remember we broke down we didn't
have cell service do you remember that
like we and and just like stranded
forever like I broke my cable and I was
like how do I even let anyone know that
it's like it was yeah you're sharing on
the side of the road forever you feel
helpless yeah the clock's ticking
yeah like that airplane still gonna
leave like I got a long way to go to
that yeah it was it was really rough and
you know my husband and I are pretty
fairly like intense people in terms of
like times of the essence and he's very
much like a hurry up hurry up hurry up a
person so in Kauai it was interesting
because ultimately we ended up borrowing
a wheel from the person that ended up
dropping which was amazing because it
wasn't for that then you know I wouldn't
have finished but barring that wheel
meant I needed a new chain so we had to
wait for the mechanics and it was just
very different in terms of and then Ana
wahoo it was kind of somebody that lived
on the island put something in their
mailbox that I needed I don't even
remember what it was and they were like
oh yeah we're gonna drive to this guy's
house and grab it from the mailbox we'll
be back in like an hour and my husband's
like how are like you can't get there
any faster
it's I'm like you don't understand like
it's different Here I am today so
there's no such thing as like he's like
a Marine Corps mentality like come on
come on come on come on and I'm like
these people aren't gonna move any
faster like this is what they're doing
you know schedule and you are able I
mean you strike me as very intense
person Terry
so Rebecca told me that you showed up
with like a three inch binder of all
your prep for the race yeah you had the
whole thing dialed right like you're
attacking this like a Navy SEAL
everything well I it is comforting to my
organized kid I'm not there's so many
things that I can't control and the only
thing that I can control is how
organized I am and it is so it provides
like a level of comfort to me to be
organized so like the minute the race
was over like I downloaded I typed
everything up like I did I typed out all
these notes of all the stuff that I did
wrong all the things that I would have
changed because I want to help other
people and then when Mel contacted me
and she was like well what would you do
different I'm like well let me share
this three-page daughter mitt with you
of every mistake I made but it's like
you're like whoa don't do any of that
this is what you don't want to do
probably yeah I had gallon like bags and
I had literally everything labeled like
day one swim day one bike day one run
because you know you want to set your
crew up for success
I had instructions like this is the kind
of stuff don't call me don't tell me
I'm doing great if I'm nan don't call me
sweetheart don't be nice to me just like
be forceful because those are the type
of instructions like you know if I'm
crying somebody I want to know
everything
like I want to know that you don't want
to talk or then I'd like to talk or that
you don't like vanilla gels you know
those are the types of instructions so
yeah oh yeah I will totally show up and
be like but then I also showed up with a
unicorn and try to get everybody to take
pictures with my unicorns I have a very
I have two different sides right and
well your husband knows what you need
and don't need and can there's a short
there of course yeah and I think what's
what's maybe interesting for people that
are listening that aren't familiar with
this world is when you're doing these
cruise supported events it's incredibly
challenging for the crew members like
you think oh we're just driving behind
them in a van like it's really really
hard work it's very intense and you're
dealing with you know somebody who's
trying to do something amazing
and you want to serve that person but
what comes out of their mouth
and what you should do are often two
different things you have to really
understand what's going to serve the
athlete not what they're asking for
right because what they're asking for it
may not be what they actually need like
oh yeah I'm not hungry I'm not gonna eat
you have to force them to eat yeah sure
they understand they need to eat and all
of those cues are important to you know
keep in mind especially for like new
people who are crewing who don't really
know what they're in for
yeah yeah absolutely I know funny story
when I was in Maui and my shoes weren't
fitting properly like my feet had
swollen and my little toes would just at
least I like I had no tears left it was
ridiculous and I had to just just my
little toes and then I had a blister on
the inside of my other foot when she's
not being like a precious saw sorry that
was pretty pretty bad but I had two
pairs of shoes and I'd convinced myself
that one of them didn't fit and I want
to try the other one
same size nothing different and my
husband's like none of them say I'm like
nari no I wouldn't put the other shoes
on he's like okay fine like just
possibly seconds just do it yet but I
think they have a hotter job in the
athletes every time like the crews it
just it is yeah amazing it's amazing
really difficult and yeah when I was in
Kona it was it never rains on this side
of the island poured rain the entire
marathon on the compost yeah oh it did
rain it never rains on this side island
and I kept wanting to change my shoes
and socks and my husband was like it
doesn't matter it's pouring rain you're
running through puddles and I was like I
have blisters he's like it's last day
who cares you just have to keep going
and in I listened to him like he could
say that where other people might like
let me stop and change and then five
miles later I would have been in the
exact same situation I want to stop and
try and change my shoes and socks so you
have to have somebody who knows you
enough to kind of push back when you
because you almost you start acting
almost like an infant like it's almost
like you're in who lack judgment yeah
like where you have to make the
decisions for them because they're like
they have impaired functioning like it's
almost like that's how you are when you
race like your brains not working right
yeah yeah absolutely
how did you guys feel on the last day I
was so excited that was party J for me
yeah I was like I've got here I'm
finishing this
yeah because like up until that stage it
was you know anything can go wrong
anything can break anything you know
something can happen that will
completely derail you and you won't
better finish and so in my mind the
whole time I'm like get to day five
catch tape five and then it's fine then
you know you're there and life will be
amazing and yeah it really it really was
it was really really fun I absolutely
loved day five yeah I had a couple of
naps along the way which is awesome
because I said to my crew beforehand
because my my old coach um he passed
away about Craig Percival when he did
that so when he did the H in Australia
the eight iron man's he would have power
naps and that really re-energized him
and helped him so I thought about that
I'm like okay I'm gonna do that if I
feel like I'm gonna fall asleep and I
was on the Queen Kay and I started
seeing dots in front of my eyes and I
could see on the bike I was actually
swerving and I'm like I'm gonna run into
a car I'm just gonna accidentally just
swerve into a car sorry I pulled up to
my career and they're like what are you
doing I'm like I need a nap so they just
put me in the front seat I put my feet
up on the dashboard lay the seat down
and just flat for 15 minutes go back on
the bike and like alright good now then
kept going and yeah like you know I just
I just hung out and took my time like
yeah this is a facebook video when I'm
at the turnaround at Harvey and I'm you
know sitting down the card is eating
chips you know having a chat my
brother's you know talking on
Facebook you know sending all these
random messages and yeah like you know
like but you were doing like
hallucinating and you know just all over
the place but I just had so much fun and
it was one of those times like the end
was really emotional for me like I could
feel Craig's presence there and just I
just became really overwhelmed with the
fact that all of these people were here
to support me like you know I had three
people fly over from Australia to come
over there I'm like who who does that
who flies you know gets on a plane for
me like there was no other reason like
they were having their own holidays and
everything else but that was the reason
what they were there at that time and it
was just that whole you know experience
about that and yeah like there wasn't
many people who weren't crying at that
time when I finished that yeah that was
just I was amazing and I still can
recapture that feeling just talking
about it now and feel like I just take
myself right back there and it
yeah it was it was amazing so explain
who Craig Percival was Craig was an
amazing man he was a huge personality in
the Australian truth on world basically
and he's when I met him he was working
for blue twirl around blue 70 and doing
a lot of wet suits and you know like he
helped me get into my wetsuit before
race that I was doing and he would do it
for anybody you just walk up to and go
oh can you help me and just like put it
on properly and like how amazing and
then you know go off and yeah so he had
started his own coaching business he had
owned aqua shop which was like a bathing
suit I think earlier like wet suits and
you know like everything and he was like
the go-to person about everything that
and he was married to well yeah his wife
Linda land two kids a beautiful
beautiful family absolutely amazing so
yeah he had done ultraman Canada the
year before I did it so I met up with
him and he's like hey when you're ready
to talk you know I'll tell you
everything that you need to know about
the whole event and everything so that
was that was amazing has a really really
good resource for me for that as well
and then he came over to Hawaii and did
the year after I come in what year that
was rememberin ships yeah yeah once
right yeah he did yeah he did once he
did two ultraman's because then when the
rest of us had done - were like we'll
come on Craig gotta do another one now
like what are you doing it slacking off
and so then he actually Coe race
directed Ultraman Australia for a couple
of yeah yeah so he brought up to me
Australia out with another guy Tony in
2005 was the first year that they did
that sorry
yeah like he was like everybody knew him
you know he couldn't walk anywhere at a
race without you know stopping legend
absolute legend in the multi-sport colud
by everyone absolutely absolutely
sorry um after he did Ultraman Hawaii he
was like okay so what else can I do so
he created his own event which was a
unite in age so as a Tyne man's in eight
different states of Australia in eight
days and yeah like he
fell over time doing that as well yeah
and you know he had timelines everything
to do like you know 11 hour Iron Man's
to get on a plane to get to the next
state because Australia is huge right
and to be out it's not a Puddle Jumper
flight from one little island in the
night no yeah it's hours hours of flying
yeah so then after he did that then he
was having problems with his knee and he
wasn't able to run and he was like
really struggling so went in and had
surgery on it
and then subsequently as a result of
that surgery had a blood clot that he
ended up dying from so yeah who's in
intensive care for about a week before
he ended up passing away so it was it
was he is in his 40s yeah I can't
remember exactly how old so it was
incredibly sudden as well and you know
like a fit healthy guy then suddenly you
know in intensive care in a coma and
never waking up it was yeah it was just
yeah yeah so that was December 2016
right so he was coaching you at the top
yeah yeah and you're six months out from
doing epic five yes yeah yeah so there
was it was a few of us who were doing I
was doing epic five and then others were
doing ultra in Australia and all around
the same time of year in May and so
we're just talking to each other just
going what do we do like you know it's
kind of one of those things I'm like I
always I need to be selfish and think
about myself and what I need at this
point in time but also be respectful
about you know it was such a kind of a
balance in a juggle that we're all
really I know I was feeling guilty for
thinking about like well how do I train
for this room yeah yeah exactly and I
mean we all knew that Craig wouldn't
want us to give up on our dreams and you
know we would really want us to continue
and not stop but it's like okay so then
what what do we do like how you know
where do I go from here because he was
I'd only like I'd known him for years
but I'd started with him at the start of
that year so it had him for about a year
and I didn't want to go back to my old
coach then I was just kind of a bit
stuck in limbo at that time yeah so then
how does Cate come in so I contacted her
so young coach Mike Cate Bevilaqua now
and she's she's amazing I sent her a
message I said look this is where I'm at
this is the event that I've got you know
I was coached by cry
you know he's obviously you know passed
away so are you able to help me and she
was amazing she just you know we had a
chat over Skype and she's like yeah yeah
I can help you that's fine yeah no
worries and then just started training
with her and it's worked out worked out
really well she thinks I'm absolutely
crazy and I'm like yeah that's fine huh
Ultraman one year right I can't remember
what year it was a couple years ago I
think I came back
yeah yeah now she won it and she did
because I'll Tremaine Canada was
rebranded and so she won that outright
like she beat everybody in the field so
I was like well someone with that
pedigree they well I mean I don't care
if you're not you know amazing at what
you do but you understand ultra racing
and that was a big thing that I wanted
in a coach mm-hmm yeah so that's why I
reached out to her and I said to her I'm
like I'm talking to a few other people I
really wasn't but I was like just in
case II say no just you know good other
options that you know she was she was
totally cool about it so that was really
good
what do you what do you guys think is
the biggest difference between you know
how you prepare for and race like a
marathon or an Ironman I mean there's a
lot of people listening who dip their
toe in some kind of race or another
what's the difference between like
mindset wise I'm not talking about like
the physical training aspect of it but
like mindset wise and experience wise
between those traditional types of races
and say epic five you know Ram which we
haven't even talked about yes you did
you know these multi-day super ultra
experiences I think the difference is my
coach and I have a joke that there's
people that do like executive level
training so there's he's got his doctors
and his attorneys that require an
executive level training plan which is
the bare minimum to finish an event and
there are things that you can just get
up and and get off the couch and train a
little bit and you can do them you'll
make it through you're gonna make it
through and then these events you cannot
do that you cannot show up without a
certain level of preparation or you
absolutely will not finish and if you
and it's not to say you don't respect
the distance but the other you know the
other aspect that I think not just the
physical part it places a lot of strain
on every part of your life and your
relationship your job so you've really
got to be in a good place like if you
don't have a good support system in
terms of your family your your partner
you know you're it's all that's just
gonna be become bigger and bigger and
bigger so if your friends are giving you
a hard time because you're you're
missing out on stuff every weekend and
you're overcome by the guilt of missing
out on yet another birthday party or
something like it's just that stuff will
kind of like eat at you versus people
saying hey I know you're about to go in
a hole I'll see you in six months
mmm why I often tell people you know
what's going on in your life at this
time and like oh you know my mum's sake
you know I've got this going on like
works really busy I'm like maybe wait
yeah you know you need your life sorted
at that point in time as much as you can
and I can't control everything which you
know that's fine but if there's big
things that are happening you know
you're planning a wedding
maybe that's big enough as it is yeah
maybe wait I think for me in terms of
the mindset stuff is I like the point
where you're not wanting to go any
further like when you get to that point
of you know this is really hard this I'm
really stunned and struggle here I find
that's where my race starts like that's
where my enjoyment really Peaks because
you have to push through and you have to
find a way just to continue on and then
when it gets really really hard I'm like
yeah that's that's the sweet spot for me
and what if those moments taught you you
care how do you carry those forward into
other aspects of your life um I guess
that I have for me it's that I don't
stuff like I I grew up as a very very
stubborn child as my parents tell me and
I've kind of turned that into a mental
strength and sorry I guess I mean in my
world in my job I'm a mental health
nurse so anything that is incredibly
stressful is like you know that's really
intense point you know it's like we're
talking about you know somebody who was
saying before you know if no one's
trying to commit suicide if no one's
beating each other up it's no one's you
know intimately gonna die it's okay we
can deal with this and so I think I have
that attitude in all of aspects of my
life
yes I think that you know so is he yeah
trying to kill us
yeah we're good this is no big deal
different I work in health care - it's
like they David Goggins perspective
exactly and I work in with it end of
life so I'm with people whether they're
old or not I am I'm working with people
and the like the end of their lives so
for me it's like I what you know what
it's taught me is I am comfortable being
uncomfortable and I tell people I'm like
I'm the kind of person that could walk
around all day with a rock in my shoe
and never take it out and that's people
aren't like that people aren't so I'm
willing to have those uncomfortable
conversations with my patient it's like
I'm willing to do and like in her you
know in your work that's your you can go
places with people and not feel
uncomfortable yeah and that's daily
that's every so in every single day I do
something I don't want to do every day
yeah whether it's having a conversation
because practice I mean practice is what
you have to do in the more often that
you do it it just teaches you that
discipline so that if every single day I
do something whether it's having a
conversation with an employee about a
performance issue that I don't want to
have that conversation but I have to
have it it just teaches me I can do
things I don't want to do and that's
part of being an adult and I can be
uncomfortable and I don't always have to
be comfortable and it's okay yeah
getting comfortable with discomfort
having the willingness to you know face
and confront those uncomfortable
situations and scenarios it's a muscle
just like anything else right and I know
that that's what makes me feel alive and
it also gives you the strength to tackle
more and more difficult challenges not
just physical challenges but emotional
challenges professional challenges the
relationship challenges yeah anything
that life throws at you right right and
it's just I mean it's a resiliency thing
yeah like it's just a resiliency thing
and you know there's there's kind of a
joke at work that I'm kinda like a
cockroach like the world like can come
to the nuclear in and Here I am gonna
just gonna be running around like a
little cockroach it can never be because
it's just you're right I mean you do you
you always compare it
the experiences that you've had so if
you if you live in a higher stress
environment or you work in a high-stress
environment like my husband like nothing
to him is that big of a deal but look at
the work that he does mm-hmm so when you
know when I people are like gosh I bet
five is so crazy I'm like you know what
was really crazy taking two weeks off
work I pick five was a vacation treat
like that nothing compared to like what
we do day in and day out so it makes it
yeah it just puts everything in
perspective for sure another thing I
think at least that I found is when you
make that decision and you're like okay
I'm gonna I'm I'm gonna take on this
challenge understanding the amount of
time and energy and focus that's going
to be demanded of you that's gonna be
required of you in order to show up and
be your best self for that particular
challenge requires you to get super
focused on what's important and what's
not in your life right and the
extraneous sort of gets stripped away
it's like what you're talking about with
your friends and birthday parties and
things like that you do have to be in a
good place in order to do that but for
me it was almost not a cleansing but a
clarifying process of getting me closer
to what is important to me and what's
not and what am I willing to sacrifice
to accomplish a certain goal and then
you almost need that three inch binder
just to guide you through your life okay
like what's the decision tree today in
order for me to get the things done that
need to get done and there's just not a
lot of downtime for around like
that I mean so yeah it makes you
extremely it just divert the looming
deadline or you know event day makes you
get extremely diligent and how you're
managing your time throughout the day
yeah absolutely exactly yeah you know I
was had this experience recently with my
coach and I was in Hawaii and had
planned all the logistics for his
brother to race in Kona
and we were talking about how it's it's
very difficult he races his brother got
cerebral palsy so he swims and swims
with them and does a modified bike and
push them on the run
having this conversation about like all
the media and stuff and I said every
every exchange that you have with
someone like you're giving a piece of
yourself away whether you mean to or not
every time you talk to somebody and if
that's not a positive encounter or if it
causes you anxiety or angst like that
you get chipped away and and then you
feel depleted right and your training
depletes you so you have to be very
cautious about the people that are in
your life and how they support you and
what they need from you because you
can't if you're a problem-solver or
you're a person who's always trying to
fix things for people and then you end
up doing all this training and you can't
at some point you've got to back out of
some of those other obligations so you
have to create healthy boundaries yeah
yeah and the stakes are higher right so
you don't have the you know the
bandwidth to kind of engage people in a
way that ordinarily would be no big deal
yeah right exactly like I'm sorry I
can't listen to your conversation on my
way to work this morning about the
argument you had with your husband
seriously I don't give a yeah I
can't I can't waste energy in for me
it's all about energy conservation and
I'm like I can't be worried about that
hmm like when I did Ram one of the girls
in the crew she had a tattoo on her
finger that said let it go and so that's
my thing is I do this and it's like let
it go
like just let it go who cares yes yeah
so what was RAM like he were you were
the what's the accolade you were the
firt the the youngest the young any male
person female team yes that we set the
achievers in female record in terms of
speed and an age where the youngest how
long did it take you eight days two
hours and 35 minutes I can't even
imagine yeah it is pretty incredible so
what is that like sleeping a half an
hour a night we did so for 12 hours
during the day we did anywhere from like
10 to 30 minute pools Wow and so we did
that for 12 hours and then at night we
did we did a 3 3 3 3
three hours on three hours off three
hours on three hours off and our goal
was to sleep for an hour and a half
during that three hours because that was
also when we were doing like a full kit
change brushing our teeth mm-hmm
so the goal is to do get like an hour
and a half to two hours but broken up
into two segments so three hours a night
total on average yes right yeah
and in between it's essentially an
eight-day interval workout correct yeah
time drawing time yeah
time time cross potential hard core yeah
what was the hardest part about that
obviously I think the hardest part was
that was the we had a crew of 11 people
and just managing the dynamics of the
people with the crew and in just being
different in having to make sure that
not worrying like not trying to worry
about how people were my job is to ride
a bike and like I can't be worried than
you guys were arguing with each other
and we had these like radio pieces that
they use where you they can talk to you
and my husband and his brother where
like they argue like they argue all the
time and by like the sixth or seventh
day they they were arguing with each
other and it every time they talked it
came in my earpiece and they were like
oh ho bro that's not the right turn dude
dude shut up finally I just ripped it
out and I was like I'm done I can't
listen to guys anymore I just need to
ride my bike so I think the dynamics
like that was probably the hardest part
was that's a long time for people and
who was your partner um her name is
Casey Darden yeah she was she was my
partner and I met her double arm Ian
yeah yeah and Italy and I and she went
out and crewed an eight-person or she
was part of an eight-person team that
road and she came back she's like we can
totally do this and I was like yeah of
course so I mean we're I just I'm trying
to wrap my head around like the whole
process of going and and across the
entire country I mean what was the
hardest terrain was it the super long
flats through the middle of the country
where he's going over going over the
mountains the Appalachians are
definitely the hardest
so everybody talks about the Rockies and
Colorado and all that and that's great
and everything but nothing is compared
to the Appalachians and the good news is
that because it's humid or because it's
it's like because it's the Kleins are
harder the climbs are harder the roads
are windy you can't see what's around
the corner like Colorado and the Rockies
are just wide open it's beautiful the
Appalachians it's not like that it's
trees it's just there's not the scenery
to look at the climbs are harder it's
disgustingly hot it's just so gross and
you're six hundred miles from the finish
so you're twenty four hundred miles into
the race the good news is we have a
place up in the in the mountains in the
Appalachian Mountains so that's kind of
our ground like that's what we train in
so we're ready for it so we were more
ready for that because we have such
close access to it from Atlanta uh-huh
yeah but that was definitely the hardest
in terms of the terrain was it a bigger
sense of accomplishment doing that
versus epic five or how do those two
compares I mean they're they're apples
and oranges but epic five was definitely
definitely a much yeah yeah Ram was
incredible and at the time I was like
it's gonna be really hard to kind of top
this but epic five definitely top top
that for sure yeah and it was it was
yeah it was a lot harder logistically
like we didn't have stuff that went
wrong we had stuff that went wrong but
nowhere even remotely close to having
five uh-huh
so paint a picture each of you for what
a typical training week looks like so
people can really understand larious
conversation because I like to actually
let myself get like completely out of
shape for things mm-hmm
Otis because I like the challenge of
just like being like all the way back in
shape how old are you no I'm 37 all
right I think it's harder when you get
too far away so conscious about Heisei
out of shape I think yeah yeah figure
eight was a relative term is a relative
term but when I am in shape or training
for something I mean I typically will
try to sweat
I swim in a master's program Monday
Wednesday Friday when I was when I was
training my heaviest training week for
epic five was like thirty nine hours so
I did two back-to-back weeks of training
and that's just low intensity volume for
the most part for the most part I would
be 35 hours 39 38 hour one week and 39
the next and literally training
basically seven hours a day and I would
do like at least 10 hours on the weekend
I would always like get up and swim
masters do his seven and eight hour ride
and then I would run for like two to
three hours off the bike so I was
getting these huge blocks of training in
and I would take Friday's off and do
these big like massive training blocks
and then like come Monday morning when
you're exhausted I would get up at 4:15
and go swell and did you experiment with
sleep deprivation to acclimate to that
like waking up in the middle of the
night and going to workout and so here
is the great news I do that already are
you doing shield training how are you
still awake
and I was like I don't sleep no no like
I told her I was like I'm gonna be up at
3 o'clock in the morning and then what I
found a 24-hour cat cafe so when I was
so I don't sleep very much and that's
the good days but when I was training
for a quick five and I'd get really
tired and I go to sleep like at 9:00 I
would wake up at 2:00 a.m. a hundred
percent awake right and I would yeah
just lets it get up and go train and it
is a gift and that's one of the things I
think that makes me hmm but you know
what the gift of being a family Mel was
like oh I fall asleep nicely yeah in two
seconds later she was dead asleep yeah
yeah I know what you mean you're like
yeah I was looking at her like she
really is gonna sleep all night
yeah like look at like who are you I
sleep and I wake up yeah she sleeps and
she wakes up like she's like that's so
great and I'm like oh my gosh I toss and
I turn I don't I don't sleep well so I I
don't have to practice with the sleep
deprivation cuz that's that's kind of my
life already
which makes me I think a little bit
better to hate trained to handle it when
it comes from know what's it what's
training look like sorry I didn't do
there is big awakes
I think my biggest weight was probably
about 30 hours and I would because when
I was talking for epic five I changed
jobs yes I was doing a Monday to Friday
job so that made it a lot easier because
before that I was doing shift work so
I'd be doing like morning's afternoons
night shifts I do they're really heavy
block of training for ultra in Australia
when I was on night shift and so that
was my sleep deprivation training that
was yeah
full on I work all night and then catch
a nap and then train yeah and then go
back to bed and have another nap and
then go to work right yeah sorry that
was yeah that that kind of protein you
gone well if I can manage that that's
okay because I mean I do sleep and I
sleep like seven eight hours a night but
i kidnap as well I can lie down the
couch not for half now I'd get up go to
work like it was yeah I'm a very good
shift worker in that way but I change
jobs and I was working Monday to Friday
so I could train before and after work
every day so my hours would probably be
between about two to four hours a day
it's Monday to Friday and on the
weekends I do generally about seven
eight-hour days on the weekends every
weekend
sorry where I live in Melbourne I'm
about a 45-minute drive away from some
really good hills I mean my heels are
not compared to what your heels are like
my longest here like probably right at
about 7 KS but but my Dell is great for
cycling right it's really gorgeous all
of Australia very much so yeah sorry if
I want to ride flat I'm riding with
thousands of cyclists every day you know
every weekend if you want to write Hills
there's cyclists everywhere and I go to
places where there is cyclists cuz in
the cars I mean there's you know people
who don't like cyclists but there's a
lot of people who expect them so then
they drive a little bit differently and
it's a little bit safer the way I kind
of look at it yeah so I used the week
like during the week it could be my you
know do a bit of strength work toward a
speed work in all disciplines so you
know my Kate would get me to you know
have a swim week or by quick run week so
I have extra sessions on whatever the
focus was that week and on the weekend
there was always heavy bike so you know
like seven hours ride one hour run off
the bike because she's like you have to
be strong and fit in swimmin bike and
then the run will just take care of
itself like we weren't focus so much on
that because it's about getting to the
run as in best shape as you can right
then to get through that yeah you can
use the bike to develop that aerobic
engine without all the load-bearing
running you know yeah absolutely you
know creating injuries and yeah all
sorts of other issues yeah and I didn't
have any injuries in my preps sorry I
was really lucky
yeah that's great so when people come up
to you and say as invariably I'm sure
they do like oh I'd love to like do this
or that but like I just don't have time
yeah I say I'm like well I make time I
never actually say I don't have time I'm
like I have different priorities to you
yeah and that's that's the way I kind of
reframe it for people people like I'd
love to do that you know I don't have
time I was like well you know you if you
reprioritize you know you've got
different things going on your life at
the time but you know if you actually
juggle things around I actually don't
have that many people saying they want
to do epic five one girl who's has her
heart set on it and she's she's a
hundred percent committed to doing it
which is amazing forward by helping her
oh yeah I have been yeah yeah I said to
it I'm like ask me any questions
whatsoever like I'm an open book like I
want to help you as much as I can
yeah so it's really good I really really
enjoy that and then the two women who
did it last year as well you know like
both of us were in contact with them and
just saying you know root will help you
as much as we can you know we we want to
help you be successful sorry right so
four women have attempted crack three
have completed it that's right who's the
third her name is Michelle Santi Allah
Santa in Chile um amazing English swim
Ram finisher arced arch finisher the
fact that she didn't she messaged me I
was literally like now why are you you
did she's like I'm not a strong cyclist
I was like uh you finished
race across America you were fine you're
gonna be fine like your game she's like
well that was a ton of years ago I mean
she's impressive really impressive in
that you know when we were talking about
women racing and that's one of the
things that I really like appreciated so
much about when Mel reached out she was
like look and it didn't matter if she
had
she could have finished 25 old Herman's
or two she was like look like I want
this to be the best experience possible
and if you've done it and you've learned
anything either positive or negative and
you're willing to share because
sometimes you ask people and they're
very vague or they want to be very
elusive about it or they don't really
want you to finish earlier threatened by
the idea of or they want to make it seem
like it's impossible like they want to
kind of oh gosh you don't want to know
about five it was so but yeah I think
it's a little different in our approach
is different where we're like if you
really want to commit and do this like I
absolutely help you finish it yeah yeah
and I'll tell you everything I know yeah
that's super cool
yeah I think what's amazing about the
ultra world is that it's this great
equalizer in sport because the longer
the distance is the less the more parity
there is between men and women yeah I'm
like when you get into the crazy super
long stuff like then like we're all in
this together
yeah women are able to excel on an
unbelievable level I mean when you see
what Courtney de Walter is doing right
now she's crushing all the dudes yes
amazing right yeah and and I love the
idea of I mean I embrace the the idea
that you know once these kind of
barriers are broken then the floodgates
are open like you know when Jason and I
did it like we didn't know whether it
was possible or we could do it and we
struggled through it and got it done and
you know didn't get it done in five days
and now it's like a thing and people do
it every year and there's like three
women who have crushed it and I think
that's so cool I love all of that and I
think it it basically puts out into the
universe a greater sense of what's
possible in general yeah so that you
know James Lawrence the iron cowboy can
go out and do 50 iron man 50s in 50 days
which to this day I still have trouble
wrapping my head around yeah but I think
it's you know that it speaks to like
that incremental you know progression of
human beings doing things more and more
difficult that allows us all to believe
that we're capable of more than
then we like to imagine absolutely yeah
perhaps relation yeah yeah I I just want
more women to do ultra racing it's
amazing yeah so if there's anyone who
contacts me I'm like yes do it do it I
mean women are women are very
underrepresented in the sport of ultra
community and particularly an ultra
cycling in long distance bike riding and
I think you know there's a lot of we
both have very very supportive partners
who are very proud of what we do and
you're out of the fact that we can go
out and on any given day we might
destroy them on the bike or run for
twice as long as they do but not
everybody has that situation and not
everybody feels like you know they can
they can do that and so yeah I can't do
it without support at home oh no no
channa it's a TS board yeah yeah
absolutely it is and people yeah they
definitely underestimate how much
support you're truly gonna need yeah it
is a some of these races are really like
a community event absolutely and people
don't get that how do you guys think
about yourselves as being role models
for young women and other female
athletes yeah I I kind of find it it's
weed I'm like no because people like oh
you're such an inspiration I'm like oh
really I'm just an ordinary person doing
fun things I enjoy you are yeah thank
you
yeah no I love it I love it and I think
it's important for you to go out and
tell this story yes yeah I don't know
the impact that your experience can have
yeah like when you told the story of the
the young girl you know in Molokai hmm
Will's daughter like that's profound
yeah yeah yeah like that's huge and
that's so like you don't you don't think
about that or the fact that like one of
my friends daughters that you know they
can't wear Halloween costumes in school
anymore they have to dress up like a
book character and she literally dressed
up like made for Halloween and I was
like what like me are you serious like
what in people it's so it has a level of
responsibility with it
sometimes can feel like a little
overwhelming but I like the fact that at
the end of the day like we're average
people like we work jobs like we we are
we were talking about how unassuming
when I was in Kona a couple weeks ago
this guy was you know the swim start he
made a comment about you know have you
ever done Ironman I said oh yeah I have
in Marin that was with me was like oh
she did this race car he starts telling
her about it and he looked over at me he
just what did you weigh like 100 pounds
when you did it and I was like no I was
just large like I am now I like the fact
that we can be like regular people who
don't look like professional athletes
yeah wouldn't ever look at us and be
like oh wow that person can totally ride
our bike across the country but then you
can yeah you're breaking a lot of
stigmas around like how you should look
or how you should act or how you should
like those people must not have jobs
like that's what people will say that's
what people ask all the time does that
work yeah because it's easier for them
to you know feel okay about how they're
living right yeah yeah dismissive yeah
yeah well you just don't really have to
run it yeah no I mean but but I don't
watch television like when people say
well you don't have time I'm how much
time you spend a week watching TV yeah I
don't watch TV right so if you don't
want say not much and then like alright
well how much football do you watch on
Sunday yeah six hours like oh that's not
much I mean people make you make
whatever is a priority in your life yeah
get a priority yeah in the same you know
when I look at the people that I race
with and I look at the people that I
trained with and recently I was at the
pool swimming and when I was in the
locker room like nine out of the people
nine out of like the 15 women that were
in the locker room showering after the
swim were all doctors like they were all
physicians and surgeons and this woman
was talking to me about epic five and
she's like I don't know how you did it
and I was like well how did she get
through Medical School like how'd you
get through your residency like how'd
you get through law school that same
grit that's I mean that's what it is
it's just grit and that's the difference
is whatever like Pete you either have it
or you kind of don't like the people
that you know have it and figure out a
way to get their PhD when you know they
weren't very well educated growing up
like those are the pea
well that are gonna excel in this kind
of sport because they've just got it I
think I think you can have it but also
you can develop it yeah as well I think
that's something that I like I don't
take my mental strengths for granted I
build it up over time every training
block for a new race I will start you
know and go okay you know focus on these
focus on that and then keep developing
and building it all the time I don't
just rely on it being there when I need
it as well so I think it is yeah you
know like a bustle you can you can
improve it and work on it
yeah what's driving all of this like
this is the why question why do you do
it what are you trying to learn what is
it doing for you what is the you know
what is the driving force that compels
you to tackle these challenges and I'm
sure the answer is different for each of
you yeah I don't know your why um yeah I
guess for me and what I said before is
trying to find a limit you know trying
to push myself and I guess you know I I
grew up why yeah why why well I guess
you know I grew up you know I I don't
feel like I'm any kind of extraordinary
person and I had a lot of people
doubting then I was actually able to do
my first Ultraman and then you know and
even epic five and sorry I guess some of
its a bit of like well I'll prove to you
that I can you know there's a little bit
air going it has to be you know that's
normal that's natural but also just
because I I want to see how mentally far
I can push myself and how physically far
I can push myself until you know I just
I can't do it anymore and like I can't I
haven't found that point so I'm still
searching I'm still trying to to go and
like keep going and go beyond that and I
guess their enjoyment that I get from
really digging deep it's just like it's
just like nothing else in my life just
to be able to get to get to that I don't
know I I don't really feel like I have
one particular thing that is this is why
it's a whole bunch of other things you
know I I really enjoy you know I love
the sport I love you know going out fig
you know riding for ten hours just
because you know I decided to ride from
here to there and it took me time to get
there
yeah and it's it's just you know like
next year I'm looking to do over man
as well and that's gonna be my next you
know massive thing I'm like alright well
you know am i able to do that that
scares me
let's do it right let's sign up so
explain to people because this is really
something else
yeah sorry I'm I know the guy who came
up with this here brain okay he lives
here in Melville what does he oh okay
good to know yeah so this room is that
Catalina Channel swim so it's 33 34
kilometers I don't know miles and then
the bike is just over 600 kilometers and
you finished at the start of where the
bad would have run starts and then you
do the bad water run at the end of it so
there's I like in the fact that there's
no cutoff so you start and then you
finish whenever you finish like I'm you
know obviously I'm gonna die over the
course of a year if you if you really
wanted to I'm not going to take you yeah
from Catalina to Palace virtus and then
you do Ram essentially and then you run
bad water yeah pretty much yeah yeah you
know it's it's another challenge and
yeah you know I said it's something that
scares me like a big five intimidated
the hell out of me and I was like I
wouldn't give it a go just you know put
it out there see if I can do it you know
why not just give it a go yeah sorry and
I you know I do like it like one of my
one of my good friends his daughter
who's eight you know he was telling her
about this and so she wrote me a card
that actually I have with me and it's
beautiful and he goes to me oh by the
way she expects you to win who's like no
no okay
she's no fresh I'm not gonna win but
yeah like you know she feels really
inspired by it and I'm like that's
that's amazing sorry there's a whole
bunch of wise in that and yeah just
because I can I think for me like
working in geriatrics and working with
older adults and when I started doing
long-distance racing I was working in a
retirement home and every day people
would get up and they would go to the
library and they would drink coffee and
I would constantly hear people talking
about stuff they didn't do and work like
me will never said I missed like the
season finale of Grey's Anatomy in 2008
or oh my god I can't believe that I did
it always had to do with like travel or
I wish I would have spent more time with
my kids and that was about the same time
that like that Yolo hashtag you know you
only live once was coming out and I
really started thinking about that in in
thinking like one day I'm gonna be
sitting in this retirement home and I'm
gonna be like I did everything that I
could like I went all of the places I
could afford to go I put my body through
every physical limitation possible if it
sounded cool I wanted and I wanted to do
it then I did it and I just like
literally want to be at the end of my
life saying like I gave it all like I'm
empty there's nothing left like I just
did everything that I could and for me
it's you know in a lot of ways I feel I
feel really grateful because I was in a
really bad accident where I got hit by a
drunk driver and the doctors like you're
probably not never gonna be able to run
again so I was a little how long ago was
uh in 2006 yeah so I I feel you know I
feel really grateful for the fact that I
can do anything because I realize you
know I got hit going like 50 miles an
hour I crushed his windshield and I
landed in a gravel parking lot my leg
was completely in shambles and so to be
able to recover from that and then have
any kind of resemblance of activity or a
healthy lifestyle afterwards I think
that's a huge gift but then to even take
it even further like I don't you know I
say attitude of gratitude but I really I
mean I mean it like I'm I wake up and I
feel like I'm grateful for this and it
is you know the stuff is out there so
why would we like why would I hold back
on myself like you know you make
promises to other people and in you feel
so guilty when you like break a promise
to somebody else but people break
promises to themselves all the time like
you always you sign up for a race and
then you bail on yourself like oh I'm
gonna
hmm maybe I'm not gonna do that or you
you have a goal like oh I want to learn
how to sew and then you're like ya know
but if you if somebody else you know you
have that commitment to them you would
try so hard to make it but I'm like you
know that to yourself - how come you
didn't end up becoming a Navy SEAL
[Laughter]
I mean you have everything you you have
everything is it - I don't know you're
no Astor this is the part that's really
funny about our relationship that people
like in Rebecca's medicine she'll
understand
so I can't remember where we were and
RAM and I couldn't feel my toes and I
was like oh my gosh baby I don't have
any feeling in my toes he goes it
doesn't matter you know don't you chose
to ride bikes yes get back on your bike
in that like when I was training for
epic five or he was like if you sign up
for this there is no complaining like in
our house there is a rule you wanted
this you do not complain he is and I I
had like a mechanical issue when time on
my bike like five hours into a ride that
was supposed to be seven or eight hours
and I was so frustrated because I was
just I was having such a good ride and I
came home he goes get your ass on the
trailer and finish he was like there's
no reason we can't finish the ride you
have a trainer upstairs right go finish
that's kind of that I've done that
accountability that um that like very
few people like there's you know you
don't you don't get that you don't you
don't have people that are telling you
well yeah you can totally do that like
when Mel's telling me about this race
I'm like wait when is it I want to do it
but you know there's got to do it
together after this today yeah well you
have to do something together we do yeah
we got to find something together yeah
we're doing race across the West in June
so should thousand mile bike race yes
I'm really excited about that so we're
gonna try to go real fast there so yeah
so that's my next goal server we're
trying to we're trying to ride it we're
gonna time trial for a thousand miles
and all that turns out and Mel your next
race is coming up quick here yes it is
from an world championships the Hawaii
for last-minute prep yeah yeah super
excited for you very excited thank you
it's such an amazing race it's such an
amazing community of people yeah
interestingly in the
wake of the volcanoes that had to change
the course right so how are they working
that this year so the swims the same day
one bike he's out and back and it
finishes back incurring arm because they
can't go to volcano the place where they
state the military base is closed well
it was I presume it's still closed
so just for people that are listening
it's three day stage race double Iron
Man you circumnavigate traditionally the
big on of why the first day is a 6.2
miles swim and then a 90 mile bike that
takes you from that what is that Bay
where you finish the swanky metal the
name of a job but you ride up to volcano
National Park the last 20 miles of which
or some it's like a crazy 4,000 foot
climb yeah all these headwinds and
everything but because of the key no you
can't go up there yeah you can't go down
the backside it's like one of the
reasons completely taken out there like
the red road that someone it's like the
most beautiful pristine part of the
whole island
yeah and washed out yeah yeah lavas just
taking the rice when they say out and
back you're riding out to where and back
to you know a good question I haven't
figured out yet when I get there I'll
have a look
[Music]
I made a binder for Ultraman yeah yeah
I'm kind of more on the Danny side yeah
I I read a New York Marathon on Sunday
and people like wait so you got you just
ran yeah and I was like um Staten Island
to Manhattan
there you go way to guys who knows like
few other bars I don't know 20 of people
to follow I would be lady it's great
right oh it was amazing yeah yeah it was
beautiful beautiful run had so much fun
but yeah I I don't really care about the
courses you know if there's hills coming
up I'm like are you about this distance
I'll be you know doing a climb or
whatever but I honestly I don't really
know a lot about the courses and I don't
look you know I'm not that prepared I
don't have a binder it actually is easy
to get lost because you're so separate
from you know what I mean like you
really needs to know where they're going
yeah oh yeah and I rely my clue crew for
that because I mean when I did epic five
I had all the maps on my Garmin just in
case we got separated and I
took a couple of wrong turns and did get
a little bit loss never figured out how
to read the maps on the garment be a
junior off course but you have to
download and like it never worked for me
yeah hostel they tell me I was off
course yeah yeah it helped a little bit
but we do take a couple um turns but but
alright so then out back and then st.
Kona and in the second day we go over is
it Station Road I think there's a new
road that's through the middle of the
islands that they have of mate and so we
still finish in Harvey and we still do
the same run but we don't go through the
koalas anymore either
they couldn't get permits for that part
of the roads so they've completely
changed it and it end up going from
14,000 feet down to 13,000 feet and a
bit of elevation for the day to bike
because I cut out the koalas which
otherwise I'll be upset about because I
Hapuna coast though before that that's
like the north eastern I'm pretty sure
yeah that's we do we be in windy lots of
ups and downs but yeah that day to bike
the kicker is that you have to finish by
going over the qahal is which are the
biggest climbs yeah yeah so we're not
we're not doing that bit anymore that's
yeah there's other climb so it's taking
the elevation down a little bit but the
road through the middle of Halle it's I
think it's like a 20 mile climb or
something so it's oh that's good yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna be interesting you
wouldn't want to make it easy no
absolutely and you know that's an older
man Coulson like oh okay I like whatever
it may be it's harder I don't know yeah
I think the elevations more but I don't
I don't know if that's gonna make it
harder or what it is cuz I haven't done
it before so I don't have a comparison
to it like I've been around the island
in a car but that's different right now
you can't can't compare to that right
yeah when people think about the Big
Island you sit and think about traveling
you think about Ironman World
Championships which is known for the
heat and the headwinds and all of that
you certainly have headwinds at Ultra
man but it's not really hot I mean it is
hot on the run but not hot like it is in
October
yeah it's not going it's really not that
bad yeah
I mean you could have a crazy heatwave
or whatever and the other parts of the
island actually was like cold and it was
like raining and
you know it's not what you think of when
you think of her walk knowing the day I
went to volcanoes like during touristing
it was actually really cold to do this
like 15 mile descent it's almost always
raining yeah pavement soaking yeah the
day after I finished epic five again
won't be surprising you went out and
trained Jason let's go and I was like go
where he's like we gotta excite see we
drove the entire circumference as I know
you did yeah then you're like wait this
race black sand beach let's get crazy in
Beach let's go come on volcanoes
national park come on we're gonna see
all these things I was like dude like he
needs a little mindfulness practice
Nabby that present he should he does
need a mindfulness practice yeah I'll
talk to him about that
we'll see you need still have your
binder okay yeah it's just like hit
pause once in a while yeah yeah that was
the on that ongoing joke when we were in
Kona we had like 50 people that came to
help cheer for Brenton Kyle and explain
a little bit more about yes it's pretty
serious if my coach is Brent Pease and
he and his brother cowpeas Koz got
cerebral palsy and so when they race and
they were invited to do Ironman World
Championship it was their fourth Ironman
hmm
they swam like a 107 which is
unbelievable crazy first time Kyle he's
pulling Kyle in a boat and then they
ride a modified Trek like a three wheel
bike that adds a significant amount of
weight it's like made out of steel right
and then he pushes him running doing a
race chair and he'd they finished in 14
and a half hours they were the second
ever duo assist team to finish Kona
outside of the Hawaii which is awesome
everybody knows the Hoyt yeah but in in
Kyle so they started a foundation and
that is what we do is like they went to
Marine Corps this weekend and had like
21 teams that finished so we take people
who have you know various you know
levels of being differently abled and we
take them to these sporting events and
they're able to participate
with other people and that doesn't
really exist so there might be you know
modified baseball or basketball but it's
uncommon that you would go to a marathon
and see people running pushing people in
chicken race chairs it's really cool
super cool so that's the whole idea
behind the groups then when we were in
Kona that was kind of ongoing joke was
there on the notebook and what are we
gonna do on this day I don't know check
Danny check your notebook what do you
think people most misunderstand about
these races and what you guys do like
when you're just when people ask you
about it or um I think that people just
think it's it's too too big can't do it
impossible you know and they they think
that we are just extra superhuman or
like super athletes or you know just
something absolutely incredible that's
over there that is just you know far too
far out of people's reaches where I
don't see that at all I think that's
probably one of the biggest things that
people like I could never do what you do
you must be sorry for you must be so
super strong and everything and I was
like yeah you know you build it up over
time but it's um yeah it's it's kind of
superhuman like God like almost that
people put you off and pedestal and like
yeah that's not I don't really agree at
all I don't have very many people
putting me on pedestal people think that
like I must get paid to do this I'm like
icicle opposite things be great to get
paid to give us so much money and I'm
like look like Justin the nut butter
might send you like almond butter and
I'm excited about that like that's all
there is no money in this like there's
nothing I mean it's the total opposite
like I'm pouring all these resources
into doing it no there is nothing in
there so it's this huge misconception
that like you know you must you must be
paid to do this let's pun said oh yeah
there's a lot of money and everybody is
you know looks like like a racehorse
yeah right I've seen this documentary
called 3,100 run and become
don't linger on the podcast actually
there's a screening this Friday night
I'm gonna do a live Q&A
there's no maker and this guy knocks
Robinson afterwards but it's about this
ultra run called the self transcendence
run which is a thirty-one hundred mile
run around a half mile block in Queens
New York I've heard about that
that's reach-in moister yeah and you
basically run from 6:00 a.m. to midnight
every day and you got a clock about you
basically around I think it's 30 miles a
day you stay on track and you wait until
you've gone 100 miles it's literally
around a half mile city like a just a
nondescript block in Queens
yeah just outside New York City and it
follows the stories of a couple of the
competitors it's pretty small aren't
that many people there but when you
watch these people they look like they
don't look like athlete they look like
just you would never think like oh my
god that guy just ran 30 100 in the
course of a summer he just used to dude
you know and the women the same thing
yeah and I think that disabuse is people
of this idea of what an ultra athlete
looks like yeah and it begs the question
of where the mental game ends in the
physical game begins like if you had to
answer how much of this is mental or
emotional versus physical aptitude like
how do you think about that I'd say
probably be ID 20 split ID mental 20
physical you can only physically train
so much yeah yeah you can only be sorry
feet and then yeah everything else has
to be my body's gonna give out before
them it's 9:00 there absolutely yeah
interesting cuz I will get at the gym
people would be like oh you must be a
CrossFit athlete or you're you're oh
wait you bribed bikes like you're a lot
well you're so big and I'm like oh yeah
I mean I'm sorry I don't look the way
you think I should look to be able to do
this but it's right I mean it's it's how
you it's how you think I mean it is your
body is gonna give up and you know I
think if you went out and did like FTP
testing or lack threshold or all this on
ultra people that are accept the six
well I think they would probably be more
like middle-of-the-pack than you would
know not be that amazing like you might
not look at people's numbers and be like
oh my gosh like look at her vo2 max is
like 3 roof what's not right I just
don't know I have a low resting heart
rate though I do like my skill is that I
can have separate already like Iowa out
like I will out suffer you and yeah I'm
better at yeah you're both miserable I
can be miserable for a lot longer than
you right yeah and how do you train that
do you train that simply by continuing
to place yourself in those positions
where you're tested or are there
specific things that you do
visualization or like I don't know like
are there things that you do outside of
swim bike run to test that in yourself
yeah I mean I do think that yeah I mean
that's the whole doing something every
day that I don't want to do forcing
myself to be in uncomfortable situations
and I will do things that I think are
miserable like I'll run for three hours
on the treadmill with no music and just
sit there and look at nothing like I
will train myself to be bored or train
myself to be miserable in that capacity
you sleep in a chair sitting up no I
used to like eat things that were really
ridiculous and then I would go out and
run so when I was training for epic five
I would there's a there's a pool that's
like eight miles from her house and I
would run with a pack on my back and
swim and then sometimes I would have to
run back and sometimes I wouldn't and I
used to ask Jason to bring me a towel
and he goes you're training for epic
five the last thing you need be worried
about he's drying off uh-huh he was like
if you need a towel we have bigger
problems right and that was just that
whole oh you're gonna say you were gonna
call him to have him pick you up he was
like there was one time there was one
time
calling them to pick me up and he would
laugh at me and be like you have to find
a way home and it's not right
yeah sorry what yeah yeah a little
bit more yeah but he'll tell you like
you're he'll say you're the toughest
person I know like he'll be like hear
that yeah I was gonna say like you did
epic five he didn't yeah well tell you
you're that he will say like you are the
toughest person I know like you don't
need it like you're fine yeah he'll
always like you're fine like you're so
tough like you're mine
right yeah all right well we got around
this thing down but I want to leave
people with a little bit of insight that
they can you know take away from both of
your experiences there's a lot of people
that feel stuck or they feel like
they're incapable of tackling difficult
challenges or their life circumstances
aren't such that they can participate in
these things I think people in general
tend to underestimate their aptitude and
their abilities and their potential and
both of you are just beautiful bright
shining stars and examples of what's
possible when you apply yourself
rigorously towards a goal that most
people would dissuade you from or tell
you is impossible yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think so I have a quote and it's been
written on it it's gonna written on a
chalkboard
and it says our deepest fear is not that
we are inadequate our deepest fears that
were powerful beyond measure and then
underneath it it says 5 5 16 which was
the date of the race and it's literally
been sitting in my bathroom since I
decided to do a up at 5 and that's like
that's what I will I will tell people
I'll be like that's really what you're
afraid of you're not afraid of what you
can't do and you're more people people
tend to get more afraid about what they
they can do when they really start to
think about it right they're afraid
like they say fear success but it's
really fear of what happens if you put
all of yourself on the line for
something right because that's a
terrifying very vulnerable thing to do
absolutely yeah of course I mean there's
fear of commitment there's fear of
failure like you know Mel was talking
about how many people like when you do
these races like Ram we had 11 people on
our crew like the fear of the fact that
we paid for 11 people to be out here
with us what if we let these people down
like that's a huge like for Brent and
Kyle racing Kona physically Brent was
like I'm in the best shape of my entire
life he's like but this isn't just about
me there are 50 people that paid their
own money to be here and watch me race
he's like I can't let them down like
it's just the that that pressure mm-hmm
I guess for me I have a lot of people
you know just going well I could never
do what you can do and I said well what
can you do you know it's like you know
people like oh you know they always talk
their exchange mints down which really
drives me insane
ah you know I just want to move on you
did a little bit of that very much so
very much so
oh yeah yeah like I know not many people
that work actually know what I do
outside of work and if you know it's
shocking yeah and it's really funny
because my friends actually brag for me
like all these you know I'll say oh you
know yeah I do triathlons and they're
like no no no no you tell them you tell
them what you do like you've done all
these people in this life yeah okay fair
enough
sorry no I do a bit of that but I also
pick up when other people say oh you
know I ran a 5k but you know that's
nothing like what you do and I'm like
that is amazing like celebrate your
achievements you know obviously you know
you don't have to do what I do but you
know whatever you're doing that's
amazing you know if that means you know
you can get up off the couch or more
friend of Locke awesome celebrate that
you know like just you know just start
somewhere like I had to start somewhere
you know everybody has to go so I think
that's probably probably the biggest
thing and I draw inspiration from other
people doing what they can do as well
like I look to other people you know
I've got you know friends who like ran
the first marathon and I'm like that is
awesome like that inspires me as well so
I draw energy from from that as well and
yeah like when you're talking about
visualization before when I sign up for
races I visualize the finish line that's
always for me what I what I think about
you know when I'm like struggling on
something and then I'll be like no no
how amazing that finish line gonna be
sorry that's yeah that's one of the
things that I I always do as well yeah
you know to that point
we don't Danny what you said about when
you start it and you were severely
overweight and that you know you could
just go to the gym for 15 min or do 15
minutes or whatever it is I mean it's
it's extraordinary what you're doing now
in juxtaposition like that because I
think a lot of people can relate to you
know being in that place and then being
afraid to go to the gym because going
into a gym when you're out of shape is a
very intimidating I was mortified I was
scared to death in the gym I had no idea
what I was doing I was embarrassed by
how I looked I were these huge baggy
clothes and that's you know when I tell
people I'm like there is like I'm not
like a college athlete like I was I'm a
really normal person like it doesn't
it's not as it's not quite as scary as
you think but you're right I mean you
have to short stuff is hard and five
keys huh oh my god yes hard as you make
them and so just don't say why I only
did an Olympic yeah only did a sprint
yeah I just did you know things are
absolutely as hard as you as you want
them to be and as hard as you as you
make them and they can really really
hurt yeah for sure but not minimizing
and you know just kind of accepting it's
also just accepting kind of where you
are and you know we went and swam
together and I course that I'm lost on
this hike and it's amazing that I'm
didn't get eaten by a mountain lion and
then I survived three hours later but
when I was joking around and I said you
know I swam for 15 minutes and she swam
for an hour and it's not like oh why
can't I swim for an hour that's not
where I am in my life right now
like that's not that's not what I'm like
I'm not supposed to be there like my
place is not you know I am excited that
Mel is going into an ultimate next week
but I'm not there like that's not and
just so not comparing yourself like
don't get into that you know comparison
really as a thief of all joy so don't
get into that habit of saying well why
can't I go out on a two-hour run with
Mel well because it's been months since
you ran more than you know five miles so
that's just not where I met yeah being
comfortable training where you're where
you currently sit house where you think
you should be or used to be
one thing I say all the time and I think
it's super you know important and
helpful and I also you know appreciate
and respect the incremental progression
of both of your stories right like it
just this is this this happened over a
long period of time of just slowly
increasing
you know the intensity in the volume and
the distances and challenging yourself
just a little bit more than you did
before and you know sure enough it takes
you to this place where people are like
holy cow I can't believe you did that
and I think it speaks to this idea that
that a lot of people tend to
overestimate what they can do in a month
or a year like I'm gonna do this thing
and you know generally people flame out
on that goal before they even get to
that year or they're discouraged because
they haven't reached some crazy goal in
a compressed period of time but if you
just commit to the process in that
little progressive incremental growth
that is almost imperceptible you know
five years seven years down the line
like look what you're able to accomplish
so it's about like staying in the game
right and continuing to remain engaged
with that goal that you seek yeah
definitely absolutely I mean consistency
is key and yes you can't look at it
something like ultra and think well she
just signed up for that after she did
our first Ironman or something I mean we
have thousands and thousands of miles in
our body right and we started off on a
very normal progression jet-like with a
5k with a 10k my first you know my first
race had a 200 yard pool swim uh-huh in
a 10-mile bike yeah and that's I mean
that was that was all I could have done
at that point and if somebody had told
you then you're gonna do Ram I would
have I would stop for like what is round
although I will tell you when Jason I
first started dating I found this email
that that I had sent him and I said it
was the race across America website and
this is like 10 years ago and I was like
hey I found this website look how
ridiculous this is
it's the same thing like the whole rich
roll and I was like and I remember Jason
being like there's no way we could ever
do that because we like logistics I mean
lie
you know he's like oh oh Jessica Lee
that sounds like a disaster
they lost their nuts and bolts no way
he's like oh no no no there's no way
there's no way and I'm like they're
crazy but then you just you don't know
yeah everybody never like yeah are you
read at some point you read about
Ultraman was like oh that's crazy oh you
know I read it no way I want to do that
that's fun why do I sign yeah that's
funny yeah we're cool how are we gonna
get more female athletes more women
engaged in ultra sports it's it's
interesting I heard someone say I have
no idea who it was but they said that um
women need to be eighty percent
confident that they're going to finish
before they sign up for something
whereas men need to be twenty percent
confident like it's just that whole
disparity yeah yeah and it had like I
look at people in my life and it's
really true like I know for myself like
I had to you know four years of planning
before I got to Ultraman because I was
like okay let's step it out you know I
need the distance you might you know all
the training under my power figure it
out
yeah yeah and if you didn't have a
binder well I did not have a find yeah
and you know for me it was I've only
just started in the sport I need to get
all that base miles before I can start
training for that otherwise I'm just
gonna break down it's not gonna be
possible through sorry yeah I think it's
getting people to that confidence level
to say yes you actually can and just you
know even like dipping your toe in the
water like you know not just but you
know like doing a hundred K run and then
okay so then moving up from that not
necessarily you know going from I meant
Ultraman like you know we did although
if they you know if they did that it'd
be amazing but trying to figure out how
to develop that confidence of yes this
is actually possible and then then
getting to that yeah yeah and I think
not being overwhelmed by the fact that
you know when you look at results or you
look at United 24-hour bike race out
here in Borrego Springs and like there
was me in Shona Hogan racing and that
was it and she's like Ram record holder
record holder for five gazillion you
know races she's had records since like
I was a baby literally since the 80s
not getting caught up in the fact that
well why aren't there more women that
are signed up and it's you know the
longer in triathlon the longer distance
races the percentage of men to women it
will start to shift and so once you get
past that 70.3 distance it really starts
to lean more more towards men and I do
agree that it's a confidence issue and
it's the confidence also sometimes
around the training well how am I gonna
be considered a bad mom if I send up for
an Ironman like am I gonna be are people
gonna judge me are they gonna are they
gonna make me feel guilty and you know
people don't say the same things about
men like nobody when I go on a ride with
a guy nobody's like well who's watching
your kids like it's you have to you have
to level that out at some point and
you've gotta so you got to surround
yourself by people that support you and
find other women that can not judge you
and support it for sure and then not be
overwhelmed when you look at something
and think well there must be a reason
why there women aren't doing it well the
reason is because we all kind of have to
come together and take that first step
yeah yeah yeah I can't end this without
taking a moment to formally and publicly
thank the great Rebecca Morgan for
absolutely amazing work I know none of
this would be possible or would have
happened without her tireless commitment
to not just epic five but you know
Rebecca and I go way back I mean she's a
big part of my story going back through
early ultraman's and has always been
like an angel there somebody who is
really of selfless service and it's so
cool to see that you've taken over this
race and you're running it and you're
you're you're making it available to so
many people and that there are these
kick-ass women who are crushing it right
now it's super cool so can you just come
over here and say hi I want to hear your
voice so this is Rebecca Morgan if you
read if you read finding ultra you know
who she is and thank you
I love you Rebecca oh I love you too
yeah we love you yeah oh yeah you are
it's a great resource to I mean Rebecca
of course he knows everything from top
to bottom right and she'll and if you're
not ready she's gonna tell you me I had
something that reached out to me that
they wanted to do epic five and I said I
think you need you to Ultraman and
they did they did Ultraman in Florida
and I'm like here's the path that I
would probably put you on and she will
help you like she will she will help put
you on that trajectory yeah so how many
people are currently signed up for this
year well we just finished this year oh
you just finished finish this year so
we're working on next year we have quite
a few events next year we've got classic
up at 5 epic 5 Canada the 565 which is
the 70.3 distance and the run Wow but
we're not going to have an epic 5 in
2020 oh you're not why not we're doing
the DECA oh my god all right
are you guys doing that I thought about
it but I need a break like I've done
yeah yeah yeah she sent me a text and it
was it was really one of those times
where it was probably the only times I
responded back and she said do you think
this is possible the schedule and I said
honestly no not for me for for somebody
who finishes an Ironman in nine or ten
hours normally then yeah I was like but
for me that's gonna be a pretty big
stretch
so dekha meaning 10 Iron Man's how does
it break down like it's to an island she
said three almonds doing - right all
right well if people want to learn about
that they can just go the epic five
website five.com is that the website
yeah alright so a few lunatics out there
don't blame me all right you guys you
are two of the most inspiring women I've
ever met thank you for being here and
sharing your story first you guys are
awesome
good luck No thank you man I will be
thinking about you and cheering for you
ain't going from afar and your race
across the rocket with the West ocean
side to Durango Wow when does that start
i gene little gene so cool yeah and if
you want to learn more about these
lovely ladies the first thing to do is
to read Daniels book fear no distance
which I have not yet read but you
brought me a copy here today so thank
you I'm looking forward to checking that
out and how else can people find you
follow you cheer for you give you a hey
what's up yeah sorry I'm Facebook it's
my name Melissa Yuri and my Instagram is
a trang amel sorry I'm gonna have to say
that what is that so um yeah Ranga is a
well it's a derogatory word for redheads
in Australia it's actually quite it's an
insult but a lot of us as redheads take
it on and just use it as our nicknames
because that's Australian way to braise
it so it's our a nga mal and I've got a
blog which is Ranga mailed up WordPress
comm which I update once a month mostly
with race reports and other things that
I think about to write about right on
yeah and I am Danny da and I understood
Gord Grabel Gerry bol on Instagram and
Danielle Grable on Facebook and I have a
website and don't do a good job of
updating my blog but if you ever come to
it Lana do you want to ride some
mountains you know you can you can find
me somehow
right but or and your weapon might snipe
no he's gonna he's you never know where
he's where he's gonna jump out at now
he's he's he's he's great to ride with
you if you um yeah if you uh if you
don't need a pat on the back if you
don't like to be calm be doing a good
job somebody he's your guy but if you
want someone that's gonna make you
finish it will be us and I liked to tell
my my last little story here when I was
screwing him for Chad he would finished
a gazillion races in the whole world he
tried to quit on me and I picked him up
through donut in his hand and kicked the
chair out from under him and said no
like I you want somebody to kick the
chair out from under you where are your
people right and I just I mean he's I'm
sure he's the guy who you want on your
team who's gonna support you and show up
for you 100 and yeah like you want to be
stuck in a foxhole with him for sure
yeah yeah yeah yep he's great I mean if
he is in he is like all-in right for
sure cool well if you guys are you guys
gonna get on a train today we've got a
swim to do later yeah yeah all right
cool
thanks again you guys thank you come
back anytime and look forward to
crossing paths again soon
Thanks
[Music]